nous sommes en milieu d'après-midi et
adam a déjà remporté plusieurs matches
de son jeu de prédilection super smash
bros ultime
victoire donc j'ai ma place en grande
finale c'est le tout dernier le tout
dernier match que je dois jouer pour
gagner ce tournoi donc je m'attendais
pas du tout arriver jusque là arrivé tôt
ce matin à cette première édition du
plaisir gaming le jeune joueur habitué
des compétitions n'est pas venu seul
depuis le collège disons qu'on se
connaît maintenant moi je viens de
perdre contre lui donc je me retrouve en
looser starter c'est à dire que pour
gagner le tournoi maintenant il me faut
remporter cinq sets d'affilée
en attendant leur prochain match les
deux amis s'entraîne dans le palais des
sports pierre de coubertin mise à
disposition pour l'événement ça m'a
beaucoup plu de venir ici on va dire
qu'après un an et demi de compétitif se
considère ce tournoi comme étant l'un
des meilleurs en terme de qualité auquel
j'ai joué pourtant j'en ai fait beaucoup
c'est quelque chose qui est dans l'air
du temps et qu'on voulait proposer à nos
jeunes de plaisir et des environs plus
qu'en fait on a ratissé un peu plus
large on a voulu que ce soit un
événement familial puisque on appris que
des jeux donc avec un âge minimum entre
3 et 12 ans adore de ce monde gamer
billups qui a finalement remporté sa
finale et s'est vu décerner un trophée
et une figurine au total 120 joueurs se
sont affrontés de 10h à 22h sur quatre
jeux super smash bros ultimate fifa 2022
league of legends et roccat league